ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. DEGREE ARE CURRY.
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND BENNETT.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAO
GEN CHIU CHOI. COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEE
LEVINE LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA IN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS WORK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE JANE RATHER THERE IS V.
APPROVED WA VOEPEL WALDRON
BOARD WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER THE
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YES
THERE CON. IMAM. AND THE NAME
OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE
MOST MERCIFUL. I'M NOT A GUN.
MAY BE YOUR WILL THAT WE ALLOW
OUR EYES TO SEE THE SUFFERING
OF OTHERS. USE OUR VOICES TO
CRY OUT AGAINST INJUSTICE. AND
COMMIT OUR STRENGTH TO CREATE A
MORE TOLERANT AND COMPASSIONATE
WORLD I MEAN. THANK YOU WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AND SHE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. MY
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND. YEAH THANK YOU YOU MAY BE
SEATED- READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL GOLDEN ONE CENTER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY DECEMBER
SEVENTH 2020% AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION
THEN PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR TODAY'S
ABSENCES. FOR ILLNESS IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GARCIA
MULLIN AND DOLLY. ON MEDICAL
LEAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
AND FOR DEATH IN THE FAMILY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER. ISRAEL'S
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOTION. OKAY MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THE WATER
GARCIA GRAYSON CHAN AND BONTA
TO SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY IS MAJORITY LEADER RACES
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN.
MEMBERS. MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE WE HAVE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT ITEM
NUMBER ONE. MAJORITY LEADER
WRATH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
MAKE YOUR MOTION ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER WE HAVE
A VERY IMPORTANT MOTION TODAY
REGARDING ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES.
I MOVED TO THE ASSEMBLY ADVISE
AND CONSENT TO THE APPOINTMENT
BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER TO THE
OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF STATE.
MADAM SPEAKER IS MY PLEASURE TO
SECOND A MOTION. SECONDED BY
FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN MAJORITY
LEADER RESCUE MAY OPEN ON YOUR
MOTION. IT IS MY HONOR. TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF MY FRIEND. AND
COLLEAGUE DR SHIRLEY WEBER. AND
I. AND I URGE THIS BODY TO
SUPPORT NOT THAT ANYBODY NEEDS
ARE URGING BUT I URGE THIS BODY
TO SUPPORT HER NOMINATION AS
THE NEXT SECRETARY OF STATE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YESTERDAY IN OUR SPECIAL
COMMITTEE HEARING WE HEARD FROM
A DIVERSE AND BROAD SPECTRUM OF
INDIVIDUALS COMMUNITY GROUPS
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND BUSINESS
GROUPS. ALL SUPPORTING THIS
APPOINTMENT. NOT ONLY DO WE
KNOW HER WORK AND HER PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF GETTING THINGS
DONE. BUT WE ALSO HAVE NUMEROUS
TESTIMONIES ATTESTING TO THE
SAME. IT IS BITTERSWEET BUT AS
WE VOTE ON THIS CONFIRMATION
THAT WE WILL NO LONGER HAVE HER
COUNSEL AND HER FIERCE ADVOCACY
ON THIS FLOOR. BUT THE LOSS TO
THIS FLOOR TO THIS HOUSE IS A
TREMENDOUS GAME FOR THE STATE
AND OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
MEMBERS I ALSO TO SUPPORT THE
APPOINTMENT OF DR SHIRLEY WEBER.
TO THE OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF
STATE. THANK YOU MAJORITY
LEADER REV MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MOTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A
DOCTOR WEBER MY FRIEND.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENT. AS YOUR
COLLEAGUES WE ARE PROUD TO HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE TO
CONFIRM YOUR NOMINATION FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE. WITH OUR
DEEP. ADMIRATION AND BEST
WISHES FOR A TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS. IN THIS NEW ASSIGNMENT.
TODAY YOUR CHILDREN AND YOUR
CHILDREN'S CHILDREN YOUR YOUR
PRIDE AND JOY WE'LL BE ABLE TO
SAY THEIR MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER MADE HISTORY.
BECOMING THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO BECOME
SECRETARY OF STATE AND ONLY THE
FIFTH AFRICAN AMERICAN TO EVER
HOLD STATE OFFICE. THIS COMING
ONLY A WEEK AFTER WITNESSING
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES TO BE SWORN IN AS
VICE PRESIDENT. I CALL THIS
DIVINE PROVIDENCE. YOUR BODY OF
WORK IN THE CARE INTEGRITY IN
WHICH YOU ESTABLISHED IT HAVE
ENDEARED YOU NOT ONLY TO ALL OF
US. BUT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOUR ELOQUENCE AND
ELEGANCE WHILE SPEAKING ON THIS
FLOOR. YOU'RE SO OFTEN CAPTURED
NOT ONLY OUR INTENTIONS BUT THE
ESSENCE OF OUR THOUGHTS. AND
FEELINGS WITH HEART INTELLECT
AND PASSION. DURING MY TIME AS
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I SO
VALUE YOUR COUNSEL. IN
PARTNERSHIP AS VICE CHAIR.
WHETHER HELPING TO ARCHITECT
BASILE B. C.'S MEMORABLE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
CELEBRATION. GROWING AFRICAN
AMERICAN LEADERS FOR TOMORROW
PROGRAM OR HELPING TO DEVELOP
GROUND BREAKING POLICIES YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CONTINUING THE
HISTORY AND HISTORIC LEGACY OF
OUR CAUCUS EVEN HOURS ARE
IMMEDIATE PAST YEAR IS SECOND
TO NONE. IT IS YOU HAVE
COMMITTED. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONTINUED INVESTING IN THE
SUCCESS OF THE CIBC. DR WEBER
YOU'RE SO OFTEN SAID AS AN
EDUCATOR. IT WAS YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY SET A HIGH
STANDARD FOR YOUR STUDENTS TO
BRING OUT THEIR BEST IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE THEIR BEST. I DO
KNOW THEIR HISTORY THAT THEY
MAY BE FREE TO SOAR TO THEIR
FUTURE. THAT MESSAGE WAS NOT
LIMITED TO YOUR STUDENTS. BUT
FOR ALL OF US TO BE INSPIRED BY
AND WITNESS AND HOW YOU LIVED
IT EVERY DAY. SO MANY TIMES ON
THIS FLOOR. YOU HAVE RECITED
THE BRILLIANCE OF MAYA ANGELOU.
TO DRIVE HOME YOUR MESSAGE AND
AT THE SAME TIME EDIFY OUR
SOULS. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE MY
COMMENTS. RESIDING FOR YOU MAYA
ANGELOU. WHY THE CAGED BIRD
SINGS. TO LET YOU KNOW. WE
HEARD. THE FREE BIRD LEAPS ON
THE BACK OF THE WIND. AND
FLOATS DOWNSTREAM. TILL THE
CURRENT EVENTS. AND DIPS HIS
WINGS IN THE WARM SUN RAYS. AND
DARES TO CLAIM THE SKY. BUT A
BIRD THAT STALKS DOWN HIS
NARROW CAGE. CONSULTANCY
THROUGH HIS BARS OF RAGE. HIS
WINGS ARE CLIPPED AND HIS FEET
ARE TIED. SO WE OPENS HIS
THROAT TO SING. THE CAGED BIRD
SINGS WITH FEARFUL TRILL. OTHER
THINGS ON NO. BUT LONG FOR
STILL. IN HIS TUNIS HEARD ON
THE JUSTIN HILL. FOR THE CAGED
BIRD SINGS OF FREEDOM. THE
FREEBIRD THANKS ANOTHER BREEZE
AND THE TRADE WINDS THROUGH THE
SIDE. TREES AND THE FAT WORMS
WAITING ON A DON BRIGHT LAW.
ANY NAMES THIS GUY IS ALL. BUT
A CAGE BIRDS DANCE ON THE GRAVE
OF DREAMS HE SHOT OURSELVES ON
A NIGHTMARE SCREEN. HIS WINGS
ARE CLIPPED AND HIS FEET ARE
TIED CECILIA OPENS HIS THROAT
TO SING. THE CAGED BIRD SINGS
WITH A FEARFUL THRILL. OF
THINGS UNKNOWN A LONG FOR STILL.
AND HIS TUNE IS HEARD ON A
DISTANT HILL FOR THE CAGED BIRD
SINGS OF FREEDOM. GOD BLESS YOU
DR WEBER. WE ARE FILLED WITH
GREAT EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
GREAT NEXT CHAPTER THAT YOU HAD
TO BRING. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
CHáVEZ BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I AM HONORED TO RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMAN'S POCKETS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF DR
SHIRLEY WEBER FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE. DR WEBER IS A FORCE OF
NATURE. ONE WE RARELY SEE. AND
WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO ELEVATE
SOMEONE OF HER CALIBER AND
QUALIFICATION RICE WE SHOULD
NEVER HESITATE. BECAUSE WHEN
SOMEONE LIKE DR WEBER RISES SHE
DOES NOT RISE ALONE. AND OUR
VOICE IS NOT HERS ALONE IT
OCCURS WITH THE WISDOM AND
STRENGTH OF THOSE WHO CAME
BEFORE HER AND PAVE THE WAY FOR
OTHERS TO FOLLOW. AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE. WHEN SURELY IS ON THE
MIKE. EVERYONE ON THE FLOOR
KNOWS TO STOP AND LISTEN. WE
START NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE WE
WANT TO HEAR WHAT SHE HAS TO
SAY. WE STOPPED BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHETHER WE AGREE OR NOT WE ARE
BETTER FOR HAVING WHICH IS.
EACH ONE OF US HAS BEEN
INSPIRED BY OUR VOICE IT IS
STOOD IN AWE OF HER GRACE UNDER
FIRE. EACH ONE OF US HAS BEEN
INSPIRED TO BE. INSPIRED BY HER
AND I STOOD IN AWE OF HER
RECENT APART SHE'S AN EDUCATOR
BY TRADE AND AT TIMES THIS TERM
IS VERY BUILDING. INTO A
CLASSROOM. WE HAVE WITNESSED
HER COMPASSION FOR PEOPLE OF
EVERY RACE AND ETHNICITY TIME
AND TIME AGAIN. THERE IS NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT WITH
DOCTOR WEBER AND SECRETARY
STATE. EVERY VOICE WILL BE
HEARD IN EVERY VOTE WILL BE
COUNTED. WE HAVE ARRIVED AT
THIS MOMENT BECAUSE OF OUR
CONTINUED FIGHT AGAINST VOTER
SUPPRESSION. BLACK WOMEN IN OUR
ABILITY TO BRIDGE THE GREAT
DIVIDE AND CREATE ACCESS FOR
OTHERS TO TRY TO BLOCK IT HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL TO THE SIDE.
OF THIS COUNTRY. WE NEED TO
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN THE LATEST
ELECTION IN GEORGIA AND TO. TO
THE WORK OF PRIOR BY STACEY
ABRAMS TO SEE THE EFFECT THAT
ONE BLACK WOMAN. CAN HAVE ON
THE COUNTRY. DR WEBER WILL BE
THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN TO SERVE
AS SECRETARY OF STATE. THIS IS
A TRIUMPH AND TRAGEDY. AND IT
IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE TO DO.
DOCTORS WEBER DEPLOYMENT WITH
AN ANSWER TO A CALL LONG
IGNORED. HER AND I'M GOING TO
FIGHT FOR EQUITY AND JUSTICE
LONG BEFORE HER TENURE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS EARNED FOR THIS
POSITION. AND PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY SHOULD BE DISMISSED
OUTRIGHT. AND FOR OUR BLACK
COMMUNITY. I DON'T VIEW THIS
NOMINATION AS AN EXCHANGE BUT
AS A PROMISE. THAT THERE WILL
BE EQUAL REPRESENTATION IN THE
HIGHEST OFFICES IN CALIFORNIA
AND FAR BEYOND. THIS I A
TREMENDOUS MOMENT. IT IS
PROGRESS FOR WOMEN. AND BLACK
WOMEN IN PARTICULAR. BUT TRUST
ME WHEN I SAY ALL OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BENEFIT FROM HER SERVICE.
WE STILL OFFICE WENT TO SEE BE
SEEN AND LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE OFTEN PREACH ABOUT
CALIFORNIA VALUES. WITH DR
WEBBER HE HOME I BELIEVE WE
WILL BE THE MODEL FOR ELECTED
PARTICIPATION OUTREACH
INCLUSIVITY AND DEMOCRACY. DR
WEBER WE'VE HEARD TO SAY SO
MANY TIMES IF YOU KNOW BETTER
YOU DO BETTER. I THINK I SPEAK
FOR ALL OF US WHEN I SAY THAT
WE ARE BETTER FOR KNOWING HIM.
THANK YOU. FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE
DONE FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALREADY. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW YOU
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR WHAT IS
RIGHT. AND JUST. A SECRETARY OF
STATE. I PROBABLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR DR SHIRLEY WEBER
FOR SECRETARY OF STATE. THANK
YOU MISS BURKE. MISTER GIBSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. I COULD
NOT BE MORE PROUD TO RAISE MY
MICROPHONE AND SPEAKER SUPPORT
A DOCTOR SHIRLEY NASH WEBER
CONFIRMATION TO BE CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST BLACK SECRETARY OF THIS
GREAT STATE. DR SHIRLEY NASH
WEBER WON SAID AND I QUOTE I
COME OUT. OF A LEGACY THAT SAYS.
IF YOU DON'T KICK KICK IF YOU
DID YOU'D KEEP KICKING AT THE
DOOR YOU WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO
WEAR THE DOOR DOWN. OR HAVE IT
OPENED. DR WEBER HAS BEEN
KICKING IN THE DOOR. DR SHIRLEY
WEBER HAS KICKED IN THE DOOR
NOW. SHE. TICKET A DOOR OF
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES AT CAL
STATE DR WEBER KEEP KICKING IN
THE DOOR WHO BROUGHT US A C.
FIVE BECAUSE HE KEPT KICKING IN
THE DOOR DR WEBER KEPT KICKING
IN THE DOOR AND BROUGHT US AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
REPARATIONS THAT WAS SIGNED BY
THIS GOVERNOR DR WILBER KEEP
KICKING IN THE DOOR AND
REIMAGINE A JUST AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY INTRODUCING
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY TO
THE CHANGE THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE. IN THIS STATE. MANY OF
YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW THE DOCTOR.
SHIRLEY NASH WEBER. LED
ARKANSAS WITH HER FAMILY AT
FIVE YEARS OF AGE I GREW UP IN
THE PROJECTS A SOUTH LOS
ANGELES. SHE BECAME A TEACHER
AT TWENTY THREE YEARS OF AGE.
EARNED HER PHD AT TWENTY SIX
SERVICE SAN DIEGO BOARD OF
EDUCATION BEFORE COMING TO THIS
BODY TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. I WORKING ON GROUND
BREAKING LEGISLATION DR WEBER
NEVER BACKED DOWN FROM A
CHALLENGE OR FIGHTS. SHE'S BEEN
A TRAILBLAZER FOR THE BLACK
COMMUNITY AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
EMPIRE NEWS AND STOOD AGAINST
RACISM DISCRIMINATION. SHE HAS
BEEN THE PERSON WHO SPOKE TRUTH
TO POWER. ANY TIME ANYTIME DR
WEBER SPEAK. WE ALL LISTEN
BECAUSE SHE HAD SOMETHING TO
SAY. SHE'S EXEMPLARY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. IN THIS NEW
OFFICE THAT SHE WILL NOW HOME
SHE IS DESERVING OF IT. SHE
LEAVES THIS BODY. A DEEP VOICE.
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND I HOPE
THAT WE COME TOGETHER TO FILL
THAT VOID BUT CALIFORNIA IS
LOOKING TO HAVE. THIS GREAT
THIS GREAT STATE I WANT TO
THANK GOD BECAUSE HE MADE IT
POSSIBLE. THEN SECONDLY I WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE. BUT HEARING THE VOICE
AND DID THIS GREAT BODY THAT WE
SERVE ON WITH A RESOUNDING I
VOTE. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AYE VOTE ON THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR SHIRLEY
NASH WEBER. THANK YOU MISTER
GIPSON. MR BERMAN. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER WHEN I FIRST HEARD THE
DOCTOR WEBER WAS UNDER
CONSIDERATION FOR THE SECRETARY
OF STATE APPOINTMENT THEY CALL
ME A BIT BY SURPRISE IT WAS A
BIT OUT OF THE BLUE. AND THEN I
QUICKLY REALIZED JUST HOW MUCH
SENSE THE CHOICE MAKES. THE
DAUGHTER OF SHARECROPPERS WHO
WAS BORN IN THE PRE CIVIL
RIGHTS SOUTH- MOVED TO SOUTH L.
A. AS A CHILD AND WENT ON TO
BEOME ONE OF THE YOUNGEST EVER
PROFESSORS AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY. FORTY YEARS LATER.
DR WEBER IS AN UNQUESTIONED
MORAL LEADER. IN ONE OF THE
MOST RESPECTED MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. SHE ISN'T AFRAID
TO SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER EVEN IF
THAT MEANS DISAGREEING WITH
THEIR OWN COLLEAGUES IN OUR OWN
PARTY. AND WHEN SHE SPEAKS.
EVERYONE SHUTS UP AND LISTENS.
I EVEN SAW THREE FROM DANA
WILLIAMSON YESTERDAY FORMER
CABINET SECRETARY TO GOVERNOR
BROWN. HE SAID THAT WHEN DR
WEBER WOULD SPEAK ON THE FOR
GOVERNOR BROWN WHICH JUST
EVERYONE IN THE ROOM SO HE
COULD LISTEN. MY GUESS IS HE
DIDN'T DO THAT FOR THE REST OF
US. WE NOW FIND OURSELVES AS A
STATE IN THE NATION. AND AN
UNEXPECTED TIME WHERE DEMOCRACY
IS UNDER ATTACK. LIES AND
MISINFORMATION HAVE CONVINCED
TENS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
AND MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT THEY CAN'T TRUST THE
ELECTION RESULTS IN OUR COUNTRY.
THE POPLE SPREADING THESE LIES
HAVE WEAKENED OUR DEMOCRACY. IT
IS ANGRY AS THAT MAKES ME THAT
THESE UNSUBSTANTIATED LIES HAVE
BEEN SPREAD TO INTENTIONALLY
WEAKEN AMERICA THE DAMAGE HAS
BEEN DONE. WHICH IS WHY DR
WEBER WITH HER UNIMPEACHABLE
INTEGRITY AND MORAL CLARITY IS
THE RIGHT PERSON TO REPAIR THAT
DAMAGE AND THE STRENGTH IN ALL
CALIFORNIANS FAITH. IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS. THERE
IS NO DOUBT THAT SHE IS THE
RIGHT CHOICE TO BE THE CHIEF
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THESE TRYING
TIMES. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
DR WEBER'S APPOINTMENT TO THE
POSITION OF SECRETARY OF STATE.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MISTER
SPEAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO CALL FOR
THE CONFIRMATION OF OUR
RESPECTED COLLEAGUE DR SHIRLEY
WEBER AS CALIFORNIA'S SECRETARY
OF STATE. MANY OF US HAVE
WITNESSED THIS CONFIRMATION
PROCESS BEFORE. FOUR YEARS AGO
ATTORNEY GENERAL CUT CALMLY
HARRIS BECAME SENATOR KAMILLA
HARRIS. AND WE CONFIRM HAVE YOU
EVER SERRA TO TAKE HER PLACE.
TODAY HOWEVER IS ABOUT DR WEBER.
A LITTLE WHILE AGO I CALLED HER
A RESPECTED COLLEAGUE- BUT THAT
IS NOT SUFFICIENT SHIRLEY WEBER
HAS BECOME THE NEAR LEGENDARY
FIGURE IN THE ASSEMBLY SHE IS
MORE THAN A LEGISLATOR SHE IS A
MORAL GIANT. SHE REPRESENTS
MORE THAN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SEVENTY NINE SHE REPRESENTS
EVERY CALIFORNIAN WHO HAS LEFT
WHO HAS FELT THE HEEL OF
SYSTEMIC OPPRESSION SHE IS MORE
THAN AN ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE SHE
IS A MENTOR A ROLE MODEL AND A
GUIDING LIGHT SHINING FAR
BEYOND. CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY
HAVE POLICY DISAGREEMENTS WITH
SHIRLEY WEBER BUT I FIND FEW
WHO HAVE EVER SAID ANYTHING BAD
ABOUT HER. HER MOCKED HER
HALLMARK IS TENACITY ON TRULY
RIGHTEOUS ISSUES. WE SAW HER
LEADERSHIP ON THE REPEAL OF
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE AND WE
WILL NEED TO CONTINUE THAT
FIGHT. WE SAW HER LEADING US
TOWARD PROGRESS ON RACIAL
JUSTICE ON JURIES AND
REPARATIONS AND WE NEED TO KEEP
FIGHTING THERE. WE ALSO NEED TO
HONOR HER WORK ON POLICE USE OF
FORCE STANDARDS BY CONTINUING
THE FIGHT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
REFORM. SHE BELIEVES NO SHE
KNOWS THAT HER GOALS CAN BE
ACHIEVED BECAUSE THEY MUST BE
ACHIEVED. THAT IS THE ARC OF
HISTORY. AND HER LIFE'S WORK
HAS BEEN TO BAND THAT ARE. IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. ON THIS
FLOOR WORK WHERE DEBATE IS
OFTEN JUST A MATTER OF STAKING
A POSITION. WE HAVE SEEN THE
ELOQUENCE AND EXPERIENCE OF DR
WEBER CHANGE MINDS. AND I
BELIEVE I SAW HER DO THAT ON.
SENDING PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE
TWO TO REPEAT AS TO ANY
PROPOSITION TO A NINE REPEAL TO
VOTERS. DR WEBER'S VOICES
STRONG BUT IS THE WORD SHE
CHOOSES THAT HAVE THE IMPACT.
HER WORDS KEEP US ALERT THEY
KEEP US ENTERTAINED. AND THEY
KEEP US INSPIRED. WE WILL MISS
ALL OF THAT. NEVER THE LESS WE
KNOW SECRETARY OF STATE SHIRLEY
WEBER WILL FOCUS ON VOTING
RIGHTS AND MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPINIONS THROUGH THE BALLOT
BOX. THAT WOULD BE TRUE EVEN AS
THE BALLOT BOX CHANGES IN THE
AGE OF VOTE BY MAIL ONLINE
REGISTRATION AND DIGITAL
PROGRESS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER FOR WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO DO. COLLEAGUES I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO CONFIRM
THE NOMINATION OF SHIRLEY
WEBER. AS SECRETARY OF STATE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
DISTRESS YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN CLEAR SINCE I RUN TO THE
ASSEMBLY THE DOCTOR WEBER NEVER
STOPPED BEING A TEACHER. SHE
HAS BEEN TEACHING ALL OF US TO
FIND THE STRENGTH AND COURAGE
TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT AND TO SEEK
JUSTICE EVEN ONE OF DIFFICULT
OR POLITICALLY UNPOPULAR. SO
COLLEAGUES. I ASK THAT YOU ALL
JOIN ME IN VOTING ON A FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR SHIRLEY
WEBER. SO THAT SHE CAN CONTINUE
TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT. AND SEEK
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESERVE A. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY NEW ZERO
EMISSION HAPPY.
THE APPOINTMENT
OF EARLY WEBER FOR THE OFFICE
OF SECRETARY OF STATE IS
CONFIRMS CONGRADULATIONS DR
WEBER.IT HAS BEEN AN HONOR TO
BE YOUR COLLEAGUE AND I KNOW
THAT I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF ALL
OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE
TODAY THAT WE HAVE LEARNED FROM
YOU WE HAVE GROWN. WORKING
BESIDE YOU YOU WILL BE MATH BUT
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL YOU WILL GO
ON TO SERVE ALL OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AS- FUTURE
SECRETARY OF STATE. NAMIK WEBER
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MADAM
SPEAKER AND MY COLLEAGUES AND
MY FRIENDS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT HAS BEEN MY HONOR TO BE ON
THIS FLOOR. SOME OF YOU KNOW
EIGHT OR NINE YEARS AGO. I HAD
NO REASON TO I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
I WAS COMING OTHER THAN A
FRIEND PUSH ME INTO RUNNING FOR
THE ASSEMBLY. AND I THOUGHT I
HAD FINISHED MY WORK AT THE
UNIVERSITY. BUT I'VE DONE ALL I
COULD FOR SO MANY STUDENTS
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS. AT SAN DIEGO STATE
AND AROUND THE WORLD AND I FELT
I NEEDED A VACATION. OF BUT
SUCH WAS NOT TO BE THE CASE.
AND SO I CAME WONDERING WHY AM
I HERE. AND IT WAS INTERESTING
BECAUSE A PERSON PUSH ME TONI
ATKINS SOME YEARS AGO.
WHISPERED IN MY EAR AS WE WERE
PASSING THREE NINE TWO. THIS IS
WHY YOU ARE HERE. I DON'T THINK
MY FAMILY WHO CAME WITH ME
TODAY BY HARD TO MY PROB. MY
SON. SOMEWHERE UP THERE AND MY
DAUGHTER AKELA MY SON TO KILL
IN A KILLER WITH ME AS WELL AS
ONE OF MY FAVORITE NEPHEWS
DYNASTS JUNIOR. THEY CAME TODAY
TO WITNESS ON BEHALF OF MY
LARGE FAMILY. THE SEVEN OF US
THAT ARE STILL ALIVE THE
CHILDREN WILL PROBABLY ALL
WATCHING ON TELEVISION. AND
I'VE BEEN BLESSED TO HAVE A
FAMILY THAT HAS NEVER HAD
SIBLING RIVALRY. WE'VE NEVER
HAD A FIGHT AGAINST EACH OTHER
IN TERMS OF WORKING AGAINST
EACH OTHER. AND THEY ARE PROUD
OF ME THAT I COULD EVER BE OF
MYSELF. THEY CHEER ME ON AND
THEY GIVE ME STRENGTH. YEAH
THIS IS A BEEN A- A JOURNEY FOR
ME AND WHEN I REFLECT BACK ON
MY YEARS OF LIFE. AND WHERE I
BEGAN SOME OF YOU MENTIONED. WE
WERE SHARECROPPERS IN HOPE
ARKANSAS. WE OWN THE LAND BUT
RACISM DEMANDED THAT MY FATHER
AND HIS BROTHERS WORK THE WHITE
MAN'S PROPERTY FIRST BEFORE
THEY COULD EVER WORK THEIR OWN
OR EVEN HARVEST THEIR CROP.
WHAT AN UNFAIR AND UNJUST
SYSTEM. AND MY FATHER WAS ONE
WHO ALWAYS STOOD UP FOR WHAT
WAS RIGHT. HE WAS HE WAS ALWAYS
CONCERNED THAT HE HAD TO HAVE
DIGNITY. AND SO HE FOUGHT BACK
AT THE WAY STATION IN AUGUST OF
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. FOUGHT BACK.
AND THEY HAD DETERMINED THAT HE
WAS TOO DANGEROUS TO BE AROUND
EVERYBODY ELSE SO THEY WERE
GOING TO KILL HIM. AND SO IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. WAS
PUT IN THE BACK OF THE WAGON.
AND TAKEN FROM HOPE ARKANSAS
THE TEXARKANA. AND PUT ON A
TRAIN TO COME TO CALIFORNIA
WHERE MY MOTHER'S MOTHER HAD
COME YEARS BEFORE. HE COULD
BARELY READ. BECAUSE IT WOULD
NOT ALLOW HIM TO GO TO SCHOOL
BEYOND THE FIFTH GRADE. HE WAS
IN A ONE ROOM SCHOOL HOUSE. AND
WE LIVE IN A ONE ROOM HOUSE.
HAD NO RUNNING WATER. A
CLAPBOARD HOUSE IN HOPE
ARKANSAS. AND SO MY FATHER CAME
TO CALIFORNIA DETERMINES TO
BRING HIS CHILDREN TO A GREAT A
LAND OF OPPORTUNITY. UNTIL FOUR
MONTHS LATER WE ALL GOT ON A
TRAIN. IN HOPE ARKANSAS WE FLAT
ALSO IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
BECAUSE THEY WOULD HOLD YOU
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ANY DEBT THAT
ANYBODY HAD. WE CAME TO
CALIFORNIA. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE. I WAS THE BABY OF THE
FAMILY. I DON'T REMEMBER ALL
THE RIDES WITH MY SISTERS AND
BROTHERS OF TOLD ME ABOUT IT.
AND SO WE CAME TO CALIFORNIA
EVENTUALLY WHO LIVED IN THE
PROJECTS THE PUEBLOS ARE BEING
BUILT THOSE OF YOU WHO LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES. AND WE LIVE IN THE
PROBLEMS. AND MY FATHER WORKED
VERY HARD. FOR ALL OF US BUT HE
ALWAYS TOLD US SOME THINGS THAT
WERE VERY IMPORTANT. ONE THAT
WE MUST GET IN EDUCATION
BECAUSE HE WAS DENIED. AND HE
SAID IF YOU GET AN EDUCATION
THAT IS THE ONE THING IN THIS
WORLD THAT THAT THE RACISM
COULD NOT TAKE FROM YOU. YOU
WILL ALWAYS HAVE THAT TO
BASICALLY FASTEN YOUR LIFE. AND
THE SECOND THING HE SAID AS HE
WAS ALWAYS VOTE. YOU MUST
ALWAYS VOTE BECAUSE HE NEVER
HAD A CHANCE TO VOTE IN HOPE
ARKANSAS. AND MY GRANDPARENTS
MY PUT A PATERNAL GRANDPARENTS
IN ARKANSAS. NEVER GOT A CHANCE
TO VOTE IN THEIR INTOLERANCE.
BECAUSE THEY DIED BEFORE
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE. AND SO
THAT BECAME A PART OF OUR
MANTRA IN HER FAMILY. WE MUST
VOTE WE MUST GO TO SCHOOL. AND
WE MUST MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AND
I AM SO PROUD OF WHAT MY FATHER
DID FOR ME EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. AND HE TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
THE GLORIES OF CALIFORNIA. HARD
WORKING JOBS MAKING ENDS MEET.
SENDING HIS KIDS TO SCHOOL.
MAKING SURE HIS ONE DAUGHTER
WHO REALLY WANTED IN EDUCATION
AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL GOT IT. SO
WHEN I SAID TO HIM DADDY THEY
WANT ME TO GET A PHD. THE
QUESTION WAS WHAT IS THE ACT.
AND I SAID WELL IT'S A LOT MORE
SCHOOLING BUT IT'S A HIGHEST
DEGREE YOU CAN GET. HIS
RESPONSE WAS LET US GO GET IT.
WHICH MEANT HE WOULD BE WITH ME
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. AND SO I
STAND BEFORE YOU AS A CHILD OF
A- SHARECROPPING FAMILY LIVING
IN A COMMUNITY WHERE PEOPLE
CARED SO DEEPLY FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. GOING TO A CHURCH
THAT FOLLOWED ME EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY AND MANY OF THEM ARE
LOOKING AT THIS RIGHT NOW THE
FEDERAL CHURCH OF CHRIST.
BECAUSE THEY PRAY FOR ME THEY
BELIEVE IN ME. AND I HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS OF OLD ALWAYS
TALK TO WHOM MUCH IS GIVEN MUCH
IS REQUIRED. AND THAT I HAD TO
BASICALLY DO THE HARD WORK TO
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN. AND SO WHEN
I CAME HERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT MY TO DO THIS WAS IT.
AND SO I HAD NO AND I HAVE
EVERY INTENTIONS OF RETIRING
FROM THIS BODIES. IN THREE AND
A HALF MORE YEARS. AND MOVING
ON TO GRANDPARENTS WHO WERE I
COULD PLAY WITH MY GRANDKIDS
AND DO THOSE KINDS OF FUN
THINGS. AND WHEN I WAS TAPPED
ON THE SHOULDER TO CONSIDER
SECRETARY OF STATE. LIKE MOST
OF YOU I WAS SHOCKED. I KNOW
BUT NO AND I HAD NOT THOUGHT
THAT PEOPLE WERE WATCHING.
THINK WHY WAS. BELIEVING THAT I
COULD DO THINGS THAT SOMETIMES
I DIDN'T KNOW I COULD. AND SO
AS A RESULT OF THAT. A MUCH
HARD THINKING AND LONG THOUGHT
I AGREE TO DO THE TEST. BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WORK.
WHEN A CRISIS RIGHT NOW IN THIS
NATION. OUR DEMOCRACY IS SO
FRAGILE AND PEOPLE HAVE SUCH
MISINFORMATION. AND THE
GREATNESS OF THIS NATION THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN IT FOR GRANTED
FOR SO LONG IS NOW BEING
CHALLENGED. CAN WE SURVIVE IT
CAN WE REALLY GET BACK TO THE
PRINCIPLES WHERE EVERYONE IS AN
IMPORTANT AND EVERY VOTE COUNTS
AND EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO BE
HEARD BUT NOT TO BE HEARD. AND
WE HAVE A CHALLENGE TO DO THAT.
AND NO MATTER WHAT WE HAVE DONE
IN THE PAST THAT IS OUR MISSION
AT THIS POINT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS SMART DEMOCRACY SURVIVES.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN SUCH FEAR IN
ELECTIONS AS I'VE SEEN THIS
PAST YEAR. AND I'VE BEEN AROUND
THE WORLD AND I'VE SEEN
COUNTRIES WITH CAN READ HAVE A
LEXINGTON EVERYBODY IS NERVOUS.
EVERYBODY'S CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. AND NOW
THAT HAS COME TO US. AND WE
REALIZE THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND AS CITIZENS OF
THE STATE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF EVERYONE
TO VOTE. AND THAT EVERY VOTE
COUNTS. AND THAT OUR SYSTEM
ACTUALLY WORKS. AND THEN WE CAN
BASICALLY BILL FOR THE FIRST
TIME. A STATE THAT IS
MULTICULTURAL WHERE EVERYONE
WORKS TOGETHER AND EVERYONE IS
RESPECTED. THAT WOULD BE
UNIQUE. THAT WOULD BE A
CHALLENGE. BUT IT'S ALSO A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY THE
MISSION THAT WE HAVE. SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
BLESSINGS YOU HAVE BLESSED ME
SO MUCH. WITH YOUR FRIENDSHIP.
WITH YOUR WILLINGNESS TO LISTEN
TO ME. UNDERSTANDING OF MY
PASSION AND MY DRIVE FOR
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY FOR
EVERYONE. AND IT COMES OUT OF
THE FACT THAT I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE. WHEN THE WORLD IS NOT
FAIR. I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
WHEN YOU ARE DISCOUNTED. I KNOW
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO CLIMB A HILL
THAT HIGHER THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
AND PEOPLE STILL SEE YOU IS
BARELY GETTING UP TO MOVE. I
HAVE SEEN THAT I HAVE LIVED
THAT. AND I'VE HAD THE OBSTACLE
OF ME. AND ALL I WANT TO DO IS
MAKE IT EASY FOR MY GRANDKIDS
TO BE LIVE IN THE STATE. AND
KNOW THAT THEIR EFFORTS WILL
COUNT. THE KNOW THAT THEY WILL
BE VALUED. AND KNOW THAT THEY
WILL HAVE A CHANCE AT HAVING A
LIFE. AS A RESULT OF HARD WORK
THAT IT WILL MATTER IN THE END
WHAT THEY'RE DOING. SO I THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR WHAT YOU
HAVE DONE FOR ME. AND HELP IT
WILL IN LIST AND YOU THE IDEA
THAT ALL OF US. NOT JUST SOME
OF US NOT UST A FEW OF US. BUT
EVERY LAST PERSON IN THIS
HOUSE. HAS A UNIQUE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THIS STATE. AND THIS NATION
SURVIVE. BUT WE HAVE TO BEGIN
TO. OPEN OUR MOUTHS AND OPEN
OUR HEARTS AGAINST INACCURACIES
AND TO TRUST OURSELVES FORWARD.
BECAUSE WE ARE IN A CRISIS OF
LEADERSHIP. AND WE CANNOT STAND
UP WHAT WE KNOW IS TRUE. THEN
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TWO WEEKS
AGO WILL CONTINUE TO ROLL
ACROSS THIS NATION. AND WE WILL
BE THE WORSE FOR IT NOT THE
BETTER FOR BEING SILENT. KING
OFTEN SAID IS NOT TO PUT THE
WORDS OF MY ENEMY SAY. IS THE
SILENCE OF MY FRIENDS. A WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT UNIQUE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HAVE.
I'VE ALWAYS LIVE WITH THE
REALITY THAT IF I DON'T DO
SOMETHING NO ONE ELSE WILL. AND
THAT I WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
NOT HAVING DONE WHAT I CAN. I
WANT TO DISCLOSE WITH THE
THINGS THAT I'VE SAID ON THIS
FLOOR EIGHT YEARS AGO. THAT IS
A BIT OF THE SPEAKER PROGRESS
USED TO QUOTE. AS I SAID SO
OFTEN. THE JUSTICE. QUALITY ALL
THOSE GOOD THINGS WE BELIEVE IN
DEMOCRACY OR RARE FLOWERS RARE
FLOWERS WOULD HAVE TO BE
NURTURED AND WATERED AND CARED
FOR. HATRED DISCRIMINATION. ALL
THOSE THINGS WE DON'T WANT.
THERE ARE WEEKS AND THEY GROW
BEST IN THE COLLECT. AND AS WE
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE WE REALIZE
THAT THIS IS A JOURNEY OF A
LIFE IF YOU WOULD NOT LEAVE
THIS WORLD. EVENTS SAY WE HAVE
DONE IT ALL BUT YOU WILL LEAVE
BASICALLY KNOWING THAT YOU HAVE
DONE THE BEST YOU COULD BECAUSE
THE WORK CONTINUES FOR ALL OF
OUR LIVES AND IF YOU THINK
YOU'RE TIRED. YOU THINK IT'S
NOT WORTH IT JUST LOOK AROUND
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE'RE
SCIENCE WE REFUSE TO DO THE
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT. I'M
EXCITED ABOUT GOING TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE NOW
WASN'T INITIALLY BUT I AM NOW
AS I LOOK AT THE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY. THAT I WILL HAVE
TO RAISE THESE ISSUES ARE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
AMERICAN HAS A VOTE. AND AS I
TELL PEOPLE HOW IRONIC IT IS
THAT A GIRL WHOSE FATHER COULD
NOT VOTE WHOSE GRANDPARENTS
NEVER HAD A CHANCE TO VOTE. IS
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DR RUBBER
FOR LEAVING US WITH THOSE
INCREDIBLE WORDS. MOVING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS TWO AND THREE ARE PASS
AND RETAIN MEMBERS A FEW
IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENTS.
TODAY'S EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HEARING IS CANCELED THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE
MEETING TODAY AND TOMORROW'S
RULES COMMITTEE HEARING HAS
BEEN MOVED TO PRIOR TO SESSION
RATHER THAN AFTER ADJOURNMENT
OF SESSIONS THE RULES COMMITTEE
WILL MEET TOMORROW PRIOR TO
SESSION. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVES THE
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. WITHOUT. OBJECTION THE
CALL WILL BELIFTED.
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY THE MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON THE
SUBJECT MATH IN MEMORY. MR
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY WITH GREAT SORROW TO
ADJOURN THIS SESSION IN MEMORY
OF FATHER FRANCISCO BY THE
RENEWALS. COOPER NINETEEN HAS
DEVASTATED OUR DISTRICTS
UNDERSERVED FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES AND ON JANUARY
SEVENTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE IT STOLE FROM US OUR
BELOVED AND FEARLESS LEADER.
FATHER FRANCISCO FUNDAMENTALS
OF OUR LADY OF ONE LITTLE BIT
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN MECCA. ONE
REYES ON A FARM IN SANTA ANA
MIAMI'S WALK ON WHERE HIS
FAMILY HARVESTED LINES ABOUT
THAT WE DON'T WAS ORDAINED AS A
PRIEST OF THE MISSIONARY
SERVANTS. OF THE MOST HOLY
TRINITY IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR.
OVER THE YEARS HE SERVED
COMMUNITIES IN MEXICO CITY
PORTABLE REGAL COSTA RICA
TALLAHASSEE FLORIDA AND PUMPING
CALIFORNIA. BEFORE MAKING HIS
WAY TO OUR UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITY OF AMERICA IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. EVERYWHERE
HE WAS CALLED TO SERVE FATHER
BY THE RENO'S CARRIED WITH HIM
A UNIQUE ABILITY. HE WAS ABLE
TO CONNECT WITH PEOPLE AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS BEYOND
THE SPIRITUAL. EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IMMIGRATION
SUPPORT OR THE MOST ESSENTIAL
HUMAN RIGHTS. THINGS LIKE FOOD
AND WATER. AND BASIC NEEDS THAT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAD HE NEVER
HESITATED TO HELP THEM IN THOSE
MOST IN NEED. IN TALLAHASSEE
BALLERINAS MISSIONARY WORK
FOCUSED ON IMMIGRANTS WORKING
THE TOMATO FIELDS. NEWS NOT
LEADING TECH SERVICES HE
ORGANIZED- PROGRAMS AND
MENTORED LEADERS OF TOMORROW.
INCOMPETENT HE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WHO ARE
WORKING IN SOME OF THE HARDEST
JOBS THERE IN THE COMMUNITIES.
FOR THE FATHER FROM THE VINOS
ARRIVED IN MECCA AND WAS
QUICKLY EMBRACED DUE TO HIS
ABILITY TO CONNECT. ORGANIZED
AND HIS DESIRE TO SERVE. HE WAS
A FEARLESS ADVOCATE FOR THE
POOR AND LED SEVERAL SOCIAL
JUSTICE INITIATIVES TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZED HEALTH CLINICS AND
ADVANCED EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. WHEN THE
PANDEMIC STRUCK. BUT ABOUT THE
BEATLES COMMITMENT TO OUR
COMMUNITY DID NOT FALTER. HE
SAW OCTOBER NINETEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED OUR
LOW INCOME AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND HE DID NOT
HESITATE TO ACT. FOR THE PAST
EIGHT MONTHS FOLLOWING THOSE
MEGA CHURCH MOBILIZED AS AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE SITE OFFERING
PANDEMIC RELIEF TO RESIDENTS.
FATHER FUNDAMENTALS WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO DISTRIBUTE FOOD
AND FACE MASKS. HIS SMALL YET
MIGHTY TEAM AT OUR LADY AWHILE
AGO BUT CHURCH HELP DISTRIBUTE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MASS AND
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY POUNDS
OF FOOD. DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
FATHER LEVINE IS THE NOT STOP
THEIR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
SEVERE FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS OF
COPING NINETEEN. FOR HEATING
OUR COMMUNITY HARD FATHER BY
THE BEATLES HELP FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR RENT
AND UTILITY BILLS SOMETIMES.
FROM HIS OWN POCKET.
UNFORTUNATELY FATHER ON THE
WINDOWS CARE CONTRACTED COOPER
NINETEEN LATE LAST YEAR. AFTER
NEARLY THREE DECADES OF SERVICE
HIS LIFE. WAS CUT SHORT AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF FIFTY EIGHT.
FATHER LEVINE OF LIVES EVERY
SINGLE DAY WITH A STRONG
DEDICATION TO HIS FAITH AND TO
THE PEOPLE HE SERVED AND I
THINK THAT'S- A PERFECT
EXAMPLE. OF HOW WE SHOULD ALL
LIVE OUR LIFE. THANK YOU FATHER
FOR YOUR SERVICE IN HONOR. WE
WILL CARRY ON YOUR MISSION WITH
OUR COMMUNITY FATHER. FRANCISCO
BALLERINAS MYSTICAL ME THAT
LITTLE IS THE NINE YEAH. THEY
CAN ONLY GOBBLED ON THE SEE
MORE. THEY SAID RESEAL THERE
BECAUSE YOU ON. NASSAU THE
OLDEST SYNONYMOUS DCI SOCIOLOGY.
HELLO MOTOR BROKING HE SAID I
AM MOST CABLE A PROVOCATIVE.
THAT MEANS A MOST K. ODDLY ONE
THOUSAND WILL CHECK ONCE HE
ENDS YEAH. DE LO QUE ESTA FALTA
AND IS DIRECTLY MONEY THAT WE
GIVE ME JUST A LITTLE BIT STAY.
IN AWFUL YEAH I DON'T GET ALL
MODERN PHILOSOPHY
INTERNATIONALS AS WESSELS SEE
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE SEE NUCLEAR
THAT AND. INVESTEC ROOM THEM TO
SEE MUST ADDRESS YES FOR THAT
SORT OF STRUGGLING THAT. WHAT
I'M MOST PROUD TO BE THE ALSO
AND YOU GOT. YOU KNOW SECOND
THAT SIEMPRE REPORTER THAT I.
RESIDENTS BROTHER FRANCISCO
ALLUVIAL. THANK YOU MISTER.
THREE CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN. BROWN'S I RISE
IN MEMORY OF TOM GREEN WHO
PASSED ON DECEMBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY. TOM WAS AN ICON
OF MY DISTRICT A FRIEND TO
EVERYONE WHO MET HIM A TRE
EXAMPLE OF WHAT IT MEANS TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITY. TOM WAS
BORN IN HOLLYWOOD AND RAISED IN
COVINA HE GRADUATED FROM CAL
POLY POMONA WITH A BA IN
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE AND A MINOR
IN COMMUNICATIONS. HE THEN WENT
ON TO EARN AN ORGANIZATIONAL
MANAGEMENT CERTIFICATE FROM
UCLA'S. HE MOVED TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT TO WORK AS A NEWS
DIRECTOR FOR CASEY PO WHILE
ALSO WORKING AS A FULL TIME
CORRESPONDENT FOR THE
SACRAMENTO BEE. WHILE THERE HE
MET AND MARRIED DONNA MARIE
FEDERAL. AND TWO YEARS LATER
WELCOME DAUGHTER TO RESET
FEDERAL CARINO. A SHORT TIME
LATER TOM ACCEPTED A POSITION
WITH THEM ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS
CHANDLER HOWEVER. IT WAS AFTER
HE BEGAN WORKING AS A DISTRICT
REPRESENTATIVE FOR P. JEANNIE
THAT TOM BECAME A HERO IN THE
BAY AREA. EASILY RECOGNIZED BY
IS A Y. INSURED TOM NEVER
MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
FRIEND AND BECOME THE GO TO GUY
FOR BOTH ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY. HE
HAD A SPECIAL PLACE IN HIS
HEART FOR NONPROFITS AND WOULD
NEVER SAY NO FOUR PLEAD FOR
HELP. HE WAS A RESOURCE A
MENTOR TO MANY AND A MAN THAT I
WAS HONORED TO CALL FRIENDS.
COLLEAGUES JOIN WITH ME IN
EXPRESSING OUR CONDOLENCES TO
THE GREEN- FAMILY AND ADJOINING
AND THE MEMORY OF TOM GREEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SINISTER BONTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
GERMAN OF MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF TOM
GREENHALGH OF PLEASANT HILL.
TOM WAS A LIFELONG COMMUNICATOR
AND HE WAS A COMMUNITY
CONNECTOR HE BEGAN HIS CAREER
IN RADIO IN PLUMAS COUNTY AND
WITH A FULL TIME STRINGER FOR
NEWSPAPERS AND FOR WIRE
SERVICES. HE HAD A PASSION FOR
TELLING COMMUNITY STORIES AFTER
BEING A JOURNALIST TOM TOOK A
JOB FOR THIS INSTITUTION THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY HE
WORKED IN THE YUBA CITY
DISTRICT OFFICE OF FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRISTOPHER.
CHANDLER AFTER HIS TIME IN THE
ASSEMBLY TOM TOOK A JOB IN
COMMUNITY RELATIONS AS WAS
MENTIONED WITH PG&E AND THERE
HE NATURALLY BUILT CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AS A
HUSBAND FATHER AND FRIEND TO
MANY TOM WAS ALSO A
PHILANTHROPIC MAN WHO SUPPORTED
NUMEROUS NONPROFITS THAT
CHAMPION THE ARTS ARE PARKS
SPORTS FOSTER YOUTH. AND THE
LIST GOES ON HE ALSO RETURNED
TO HIS ROOTS PUTTING HIS RADIO
SKILLS BACK TO USE HOSTING A
POPULAR BAY AREA PODCAST IN
RECENT TIMES OVER THE SUMMER I
HAD THE HONOR. OF BEING HIS
GASSED AS WE TALKED ABOUT THE
NATION'S RACIAL JUSTICE
RECKONING THE STATE BUDGET AND
OUR COLLECTIVE RESPONSE THE
CODE NINETEEN. TOM WAS A KIND
AND THOUGHTFUL MAN HE WAS
FILLED WITH WARMTH AND
GENEROSITY. HE HAD A SMILE THAT
LIT UP THE ROOM A BIG
PERSONALITY AND AN EQUALLY BIG
HEART. TOM EFFORTLESSLY BUILT
LIFELONG FRIENDSHIPS AND THOSE
CONNECTIONS HAVE CREATED A
LASTING LEGACY THROUGHOUT THE
BAY AREA. AND BEYOND I ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF TOM MARINO. THANK YOU
MR BONTA. I KNOW THAT I ENJOYED
MANY OF HIS SMILES IN MY OFFICE
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE GOT TO
WORK TOGETHER AND HE WILL BE
MISSED BY ME AND MY TEAM AS
WELL. MR CHAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TODAY TO DROWNED IN THE
MEMORY OF MISTER MICHAEL
ABBOUD. THE FOR MICHAEL BOYD
WAS RETIRED NAVY VETERAN WHO
UNEXPECTEDLY DIED ON JANUARY
NINTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE PRIOR
TO HIS MILITARY SERVICE MICHAEL
GROUP IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION AND GRADUATED
FROM ST FRANCIS HIGH SCHOOL.
AND LA CAñADA FLINTRIDGE AT
CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY IN THE CITY
OF ORANGE AFTER GRADUATING FROM
CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY MICHAEL
SERVE THE UNITED STATES NAVY
THE COMPRESSIBLE PRIDE IN
SERVING OUR COUNTRY. MICHAEL
WAS AWARDED SEVERAL MEDALS. FOR
HIS TOP MARKSMANSHIP AND MANY
OTHER CHANNELS DURING HIS TIME
IN THE NAVY. UPON HIS RETURN
FROM BAHRAIN WERE YOU WHAT WAS
LAST STATIONED MICHAEL FOR A
CAREER IN REAL ESTATE. LOS
ANGELESWHERE YOU EVENTUALLY
JOINED BERKSHIRE HATHAWAY.
MICHAEL HAS A DEEP ROOTED FAITH
AND EXEMPLIFIED THIS-
SELFISHNESS AND THROUGH HIS
GIVING NATURE. MICHAEL DONATED
TO VARIOUS CHARITIES ACROSS THE
GLOBE INCLUDING VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS GROUPS THAT HELP
PEOPLE FOR EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS EVEN ORPHANAGES IN
EGYPT. BETWEEN HIS MILITARY
SERVICE HIS FAITH AND HIS
DEVOTION TO HIS CAREER AND TO
HIS FAMILY THERE'S NO MYSTERY
AS TO WHY MICHAEL DAWSON WAS
TROY LOVE AND ENERGY INTO ALL
THE LIVES OF ALL THOSE WHO KNEW
HIM. MICHAEL SURVIVED BY HIS
PARENTS. DOCTORS ANTHONY AND
THERESA BOOT AND HIS SISTER
CHRISTINE. IS BROTHER IN LAW
ERIC. WELL MICHAEL BOONE IS NO
LONGER WITH US PHYSICALLY HIS
GENEROSITY KINDNESS AND AS WELL
FOR OTHERS WILL REMAIN AND WILL
LIVE ON. I HUMBLY ASK THAT WE
TURN IN THE MEMORY. MISTER
MICHAEL ABBOUD. THANK YOU
MISTER TEN MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAME SUGGESTS WE PRINT IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS FOR
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. THE SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS THURSDAY JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION AT
NINE AM FRIDAY JANUARY TWENTY
NINTH NO FLOOR SESSION AND NO
CHECK IN SESSION. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HERE IN OVER
THE RECESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MR BONTA MOVIE MR GRAYSON
SECOND THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH AT NINE
AM.